tens of thousands of demonstrators
crowded streets across Venezuela as a
cloud of uncertainty hangs over the
future of the South American country
protesters clashed with government
forces in a number of cities nationwide
Wednesday police use tear gas and rubber
bullets to batter back demonstrators
hundreds were arrested and at least two
people were killed although we are ok
this is a government in the final phase
of how these regimes behave one
opposition leader said it is becoming a
21st century dictatorship protesters are
outraged at the leadership of president
Nicolas Maduro Malouda recently tried to
use the Supreme Court to limit the power
of the legislature and the socialist
country has been slammed by a
devastating economic crisis resulting in
food shortages and increased crime
yesterday the u.s. denounced the
violence by government forces we are
concerned that the government of madura
is violating its own constitution and is
not allowing the opposition to have
their voices heard President Maduro held
his own counter rally on Wednesday
telling a sea of red dress supporters
the protests are an attempted coup and
also threatening the opposition leader
home to the world's largest oil reserves
Venezuela has enjoyed an economic
partnership with Russia this is a very
tricky situation if water da Gomez is an
expert of emerging economies and a
member of the Council on Foreign
Relations Putin is going to be resolved
in supporting maduros decision we have
to remember Venezuela has won the
largest oil reserves in the region it's
teen is a huge economy for Russia and
potentially doing trade with with Russia
in a long term their relationship is
going to improve and strengthen with
Putin and Maduro and slow
for CBS this morning and while bohorquez